The Joe Rogan experience.
Everything I did like, you know,
that did, I did outside of music when I
tried it. Like for instance, paint ball,
when it went into paint ball, there
was a price on my head. Every game,
every body wanted to give me extra shots.
So like if I got hit well I'm walking out,
I would get 10 20 extra paint
balls to my back. Oh. You know,
and we'd give it right back to them,
you know,
in the very next game when
we played them guys again,
we were making sure to give
them that right back. You
got deep into this. Oh yeah,
it was, man, it's addicting
that I got to tell you. Um,
if there's any physical
activity that is addicting,
it is painful because it's chest with
guns because it's so fast and so close and
you gotta think of a strategy, you
know, it's not all shooting straightway.
It's all shooting angles and getting
your guys to positions to get those guys
out, to keep moving up, to get their flag,
wipe them out and bring the flag back.
Now there restrictions on power. Like
the power of the guns. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
I believe you can't shoot above 300 PSI.
I think it's,
I think it's a,
the highest you can shoot us maybe
to 85 to 90 at least at the time.
If you go balls out, if you wanted
to get the ultimate paintball gun,
what does that, oh man it's, it's,
it's hard because we were using
different guns at the time cause it's,
it's like a, each year a better gun
comes out, the technology gets better.
So you know, we were using it
first when we started these,
these guns called angels and then we went
over into uh, these other guns. Fuck,
I can't remember the name of them,
but they were light.
I mean the best thing is
to have a light gun with,
with the trigger that you can fan see.
Cause that's the technique to get it
to shoot like a, like an Uzi. Right.
You're not supposed to be able to pull
the trigger and multiple balls come out
with one pool.
It's supposed to be that the gun
shoots as fast as your, your, your,
your two fingers or three can toggle.
So if you get a rhythm,
you could shoot that thing
like a fucking Uzi, you know,
and everybody has a different
position, you know, like mine,
I was like one of the quarterbacks,
which is the last three on the line.
See it's like a football field,
right?
You got the 50 and there's obstacles at
the 50 and in between and it's mirrored
on the other side.
The quarterbacks play the back and they
shoot a whole bunch of paint so that the
other guys that are the front and
mid guys can get into these different
positions to shoot the other guys out.
So the guys in the back were
shooting the most paint.
So you have to use that fanning
um, style. So using three fingers,
three fingers, cause the trigger
where your, where the, the,
the base where you're pulling the trigger.
You can fit three fingers there. Yeah,
it's really for two. But you
could fit three. Yeah. This,
this was our team right here.
Still on assessments and disaster.
And we were always pretty
stoned when we're playing.
Did that help? Yeah, the, the,
the furthest we went, we took third
place in one tournament. Wow. You guys.
So this is crazy.
Like you guys have these barriers in
shed and these are all blow up barriers
right here. It's like a football field.
Yeah. That's what they would replicate.
Like a football, soccer
field. And uh, you know,
you put all the, these,
these obstacles up,
these blow up obstacles and uh,
they're all just positions to,
to try to take, to um, get a
better angle on the other side.
And what's the, what's the ultimate
goal to take everybody out? It's uh,
you get points for taking
the other side out,
but you get the maximum points getting
their flag and bringing it back to
yourself.
And you know,
you get points for how many guys on
your side that are still alive. So,
you know, you would get 100% if
all seven of your guys were alive,
you killed all of them and brought their
flag. That ever happened? Oh yeah. Damn.
Who are you playing? Uh, you
know, crawling around the
shed to thing about painful,
right? Is it, let's just say there's
six tiers, right? There's the pros,
there's a semi-pros, there's the amateurs,
there's the novice, there's the rookie.
And uh, each, each,
each tier had at least 200 teams
competing in this wow per tournament.
And these guys back in that time,
I don't know how, how it is now,
cause I haven't competed in a long time,
but they would do five tournaments a year.
One would be in Huntington beach,
the biggest one. And it was awesome.
They would throw it, you know,
right next to a surfing tournament.
So like it would just be
cross people crossing up,
watching the surfers and they
come and watch and the painful,
then it would hit to,
you know,
Boston and Florida and um,
Las Vegas and one other, one
other place. I can't remember.
But we would do these tournaments. I was
doing them for like four or five years.
And the guy before me that was
the, the ambassador was, uh,
one of the,
one of the BGS [inaudible]
the one who passed away first.
I'm very good. It was embarrassing. Now
he's the one that always wear the hat.
Um, he was the shorter
one. So he was a paintball.
He was a paintball feeling like myself.
He owned the store.
He had a team,
I think it was based out of Florida,
out of Miami and he would compete
up until when he passed away.
He was like the ambassador
and I kind of is. Yeah.
I came in and took his spot when
he's, yeah, Maurice. Maurice gift.
That's crazy. I had no idea. Yeah. Wow.
You guys are armored the Fuck Up, Huh?
These things want to sting.
Oh Man.
I mean I'd leave with at
least 20 paintball bruises,
you know, Pr, you know in one
sitting and you know you're, you're,
you look like a leopard coming.
Wow. Coming off after that,
you know who else was a big paint ball
enthusiasts was William Shatner. Really?
Yeah. He would hold these
crazy tournaments like in
Trekkie style where it's a
scenario game. Meaning that,
okay, here's the castle.
I'm going to be in the castle right
here. You guys got it? Siege the castle.
And if you guys can
come get me out of here,
you guys win this round and they
would see it through the three days.
They'd set up different scenarios.
Like there you go to William Shatner
play a pay phone. This is crazy.
I would've never guessed. But how does
he run? He can't run well no, he is old.
He doesn't run. They, they put him
in a central place and he'll shoot.
Sometimes he would go out there but
so he would just stay put. Yeah,
he would staple it. You would have
to protect him. Old Man paint ball.
He would fight too. He would fight
too, but he would, he would, you know,
they would be trying to protect
him. Oh, that's so crazy. Yeah. Wow.
And uh, I mean there's a
bunch of celebrities that,
that paint bald man will
Smith was paintballing before
he did I robot. Oh really?
He did that. He came down to the
park where we would practice that we,
we played with him and his team.
Um, but it was a scenario game.
Joaquin Phoenix,
we MCI Pfeiffer a made be surprised
how many it looks like fun.
I guess I shouldn't be surprised.
You let off steam. Yeah.
And how many people on a team?
On on a con, a competition team.
You have a,
uh,
you have 11 for the roster and seven
play at a time and you can, you know,
switch guys out.
But now it's different.
Now they do like five
men in three men teams.
I don't know anything about the
new style, but you know, they,
they constantly call me back cause I'm
in better shape than I was when I played.
I was a little bit heavier than
that's why I was at quarterback.
You know, I wasn't running too fast then,
but you know that they always hit me,
man. I'll always get hit on my DM
on ige or Twitter. Like, hey man,
when you come back to the paypal
feeling like, ah, when I get time,
which is probably never, but it seems
like a a big time suck. Loved it man.
I loved playing the game.
It was so addicting. It was
hard to pull away from it.
I would even at times becoming home from,
from a tour straight into a tournament.
Like I'd get off the plane,
I'd have somebody have my paint balls,
shit ready and boom,
straight to the tournament. I can't tell
you how many times I was doing that.
Yeah. It's fucking crazy. It's, it's funny
when things get in your blood, right.
Getting your bones. Yeah. That got
in my blood, like martial arts did.
Cause I was always like an enthusiast,
like, you know, for, for a long time,
you know? And uh, when I
finally started training,
I was trained in like seven days a week.
Man.
I wouldn't give myself any
time off because I wanted
to learn fast and I wanted
to absorb it, you know? Yeah.